oh my god
hi i'm juan soto and i'm hitting the
town with a little bit of help on my
west fargo active cash visa card
hey what's up my man how you doing
what's going on thanks for coming out to
climb up to him so she's gonna try to
play some golf you got your putter right
here oh yeah
this is a lefty one because i'm lefty i
need a lefty that's true
[Laughter]
it's reversible so either side all right
all right i don't know much about this
so you got to let me know i hope you
don't mix with my swing
if you play against me anything i'm
gonna be competitive i'm gonna be trash
talking i'm gonna be everything
well when i'm in home play i just try to
keep my mind clear
just getting my job done
you're right
you got on camera
next
we're going to the frame store
i just want to fix a couple pictures
that i have and hang it in my wall and
my new house is not i'm done how are we
doing i just came in to just find out if
we can
can help me out with these pictures
little things right here
you'll lose a little bit but we'll keep
you here this time
yeah that would be great one i bought
something for you
whoa
that was very quick
your mom sent it in as a surprise oh my
god
that's great oh my god you're really
surprised
that's my family they've been there
since day one and
a hundred homer when that happened they
were watching the game that was really
emotional for me i'm glad you know yeah
thank you it's really nice doing
business
well before i go home i got to grab some
food i'm from dominican republic
i would love to get some caribbean food
hey what's up guys hey how you doing
good to have you welcome all good all
good just looking for a good canadian
food well came to the right place jerk
chicken combination just want something
that makes me feel at home excellent you
can't beat it but it's a home run for
you
for sure
when you come to the states it's just a
big change
and one thing feel like your home is
just the food
oh yeah baby
that was fun that we're shopping and
hanging out today i would love to stay
here it's a great city great people
around here and i love that our
unlimited two percent cash reward on my
purchases with my wells fargo active
cash card see you later
[Music]